so you put 60k into crypto and you got
hacked and you lost everything how did
you feel
we've been working together now for
about four months and you've done five
property deals we had a full 500 pound
booking come through just as we were
driving them today and this flip that
you're doing so how much you buying it
for it was on the market for 270 and we
secured it through 235. and then the end
value for the valuation came in at 370.
I love the way you just dropped the 500
pound like it's nothing and out of the
Fall there what's the sort of profit at
the moment between two and a half and
three grand I remember saying talk to me
what's going on and you were saying look
is there anybody that's freaking out and
I said who said that Sarah speak up
Sarah and I remember saying to you on
that call in about three months you're
gonna be on winners on a Wednesday
so thank you for coming to my house
we've been working together now for
about four months and you've done four
or five property deals yes so we've done
uh we've got our fourth we're into sa
we've secured that uh last month
actually that one live this month and um
we're just in the process of purchasing
properties which are going to flip
correct yeah so I'm really excited
you're making a full-time income from
property now yeah yeah I'm still working
full-time actually but your income's
replaced um and in the meantime I'm
working just so we can just accelerate
our growth I think more what I wanted to
do this interview is pick your brain on
what you've done how it's happened go
through the struggles because I know
they've been struggles challenges of
running the portfolio and hopefully
people will learn about how to get into
property so what was your first deal
that you did and how did you secure it
that was the apartment in Leicester city
center there's a lot of studio apartment
which we've still got after when going
on all your training and stuff we
approach them through open rent and
through some discussions and
negotiations she agreed to meet with us
understand that we want a company let
and then yeah she met us and she asked
all the questions and objections that
she had and she was happy with the
arrangement and we secured it there and
then yeah and then you very quickly got
another one and another one and another
one and then freaked out
and as I said to you before off camera I
want to hear the good the bad the ugly
everything so was it easy getting the
deals or did you struggle did you Breeze
that part I think for us when we meet
people in person it's a lot easier for
us to like secure that deal and you've
got good jobs so there's no problem with
referencing yeah because some people
trying to get rent to rent you know
they've got no credit they've got no
income and they find it near impossible
of course it is possible but for you
you breathed that that was nice and easy
yeah we're really lucky actually the
first house well the flat that we took
on she didn't even ask for a credit
credit search or anything like that
there's no guarantee or anything like
that she just she wanted I think she
tested the model herself before just
didn't have time for it and she was
happy for us to kind of take it on
that's interesting and equally we had a
little bit of experience with service
accommodation because we ran a couple of
rooms out of our house we just refund
the house anyway so it was all nice and
fresh so we thought well why don't we
just put a little bit into it rent a
couple of rooms out and see what they do
and they were really busy actually so we
like knew there was demand in the area
yeah yeah and and that gave us
credibility to say look we understand
the model we know how to do it we do
this already yeah
um and then that helped us I think
secure and you were originally from
Scotland and you were born and bred in
Hong Kong yes uh now living in Leicester
and you actually met uh ironically at a
property course not with me but a few
years ago at a property course so that
was kind of the common link what was it
about property that made you or you want
to get into it like what was the what's
the reason
um I think it's a series reasons
actually I think we've always I think
the financial security that comes from
it as well building assets and like I
wasn't like obviously married or
anything I had kids at the time but I
was very close to my parents I just
wanted to give them that kind of secure
future whilst being able to spend time
with them as well like as a chartered
accounting they're just spending hours
and hours at work and I wanted to kind
of step away from that and equally I
think I kind of I came to a point in my
career where I was like actually I'd
like to try something different so
there's a bit of that
um but there's an interesting story
around that as well which is why we've
come back to property now four years
later
um but I'll let you yeah I mean for me
it's the very similar reasons Financial
Security you know be able to give back
to your parents being able to help in
the retirement and all that sort of
stuff but equally there's I just wanted
to build my own dreams rather than
working for somebody else and building
theirs for personal growth I guess as
well yeah yeah
and when you started out on the property
journey I mean you're an accountant so
you're a numbers well what type of
accounts
um so I've I've done Financial
Accounting um but very much corporate
background so I've worked with big
companies what when you first heard
about the rent to rent model did you
think yeah straight away were you a bit
skeptical about it where were you at
when you first heard the whole process
works I think we were a little bit
skeptical it's just hard to believe that
you know when someone's paying you a
secured amount of rent you're like how
can you top that like how can you make
more money from just the normal like 1
200 that you pay in rent every month but
yeah we were actually following a couple
people on Instagram that were doing in
the us but we met we've never actually
seen anyone do in the UK before and I
was like maybe it works in the US but
not in the UK and you promised yourself
when you came to the one pound event you
promised to each other that you wouldn't
register for any Advanced Training yeah
we did what happened I'll be honest with
you Samuel like I think just watching
you in person made a huge huge
difference I grew at that point where
like we're not really trusting anyone
I'll be honest with improperty but you
just come across as a very very genuine
person and
it was I think it was more of that you
just you know when you just connect with
people and you're just like you know
what I see something this person
actually genuinely wants to help and
we're like you know it's hard to trust
sometimes but and then you go to the
full hog went on to the academy talked
to me about I hope you don't mind asking
you about this but you had a bit of a
wobble when you just joined the academy
you'd shout out a huge amount of money
you just put even more money down I'm
getting some rent to rent and then you
were like I don't know if this is gonna
work I don't ever want to do this and
that was a serious
you know and we spent obviously a lot of
time on the phone with you on the
masterminds we talked a lot and you were
very open and I remember saying on the
Mastermind be open don't if you've got a
concern or a problem or you're worried
or talk about it let's let's do it and I
know you spoke to Tony a lot and could
you talk through a bit about what
happened yeah well we not long secured
the first one and it was running live
and we're like we're not getting a lot
of bookings and then we were in the
process of securing the second one which
was a bigger step up because it was a
four bedroom house so the rent was more
expensive the bills were more expensive
and were like freaking out I don't have
to speak to you and then Tony and then I
remember you asked us to share it on the
Mastermind so we did and then the very
next day we got booking for like 12
nights I remember saying on that
Mastermind I remember saying talking to
me what's going on and you were saying
look is there anybody that's freaking
out wouldn't or is there anyone that's
not getting bookings is really concerned
and I said who said that Sarah speak up
Sarah I just remember and I was like
talk to me and you spoke up and I
remember saying to you on that call in
about three months you're gonna be on
winners on a Wednesday
I did say I called it I said it's normal
because it was I think February sort of
time
Very Bad season you had zero reviews so
to have a slow start with it's normal
this is part of the business and we
obviously worked with him through that
and thank God it picked up very quickly
yeah and then you ended up getting a lot
more properties because the interesting
thing about that period was it was only
me that I joined the academy right and
then we won't do that little Panic phase
and then literally a month after like
Brendan's joining so we're like we
obviously felt that confidence up in
that it's open it because parenting to
me he said oh he said um Sarah and the
academy goes I think we might need to
give her a refund you know because she's
a little bit on you know I'm not he goes
I'll have a chat with it though yeah and
we'll see but he goes she's got so much
potential and she's got this problem
she's not and I was like oh cool we
talked with her I was a bit and then you
were at the dinner and then Brandon's
I'm joining an academy just suddenly
just like a massive YouTube I was so
happy about that what did you do do you
think to turn things around a bit on
there or was it just a case of you were
just nervous did it I think just because
like I spent literally tens of thousands
at that point in previous property
courses I I was I think it was just fair
more than anything we're taking the
plunge like in the Heat of the Moment
and then I was like oh what if it's a
repeat of what happened last time and
that's I think where the fear came from
but then like actually speaking to Tony
as well and you know just everyone that
reached out actually at the time there's
just a lot of support and it really is
and even you just you know addressing
that issue personally with us on that
Mastermind really helped because it just
it just shows that there's help at hand
it's not like you're kind of left your
own device and then you figure it out
yourself like there's people there to
support you and not only that when when
you raise the issue that week the next
week you followed up with us to ask how
it was going what's changed and that for
us in a room or a zoom call with 200
people on there that that stood out for
well certainly me with I think Sarah as
well that yeah he actually cares and he
takes notes and he listens and and he
wants to make sure everyone's we obsess
over the academy members we're obsessed
you know suffocate people into success
when people register for the Academy
that's the beginning it's not like all
right okay cool the registered now our
job's done let's go and run the crash
course like that's the beginning in the
journey for us obviously I'm not perfect
and we're not perfect and there is
struggles in the business and there's
genuine when you run the property
business there is highs and lows but um
no it was great to see that the day
after things suddenly suddenly picked up
since then you've got quite a few more
properties so where are your portfolio I
know you've got something Leicester but
you've also got some in the Matlock area
correct yeah so we've got two in Matlock
right now which are more holiday let's
and then we've we like I said we secured
one uh last month in Leicester so we've
got two in Leicester now and the one we
did um last month well we secured it
last month went live this month we've
done that on a room by room basis like
with the locks kind of HMO style but you
know not so much HMO
um and that's been getting consistent
booking so like when we're looking at
our uh Financial numbers right now we
actually reinvested a lot of our profits
back into this fourth essay right but
touchwood book just hadn't we had a 500
pound booking come through just as we
were driving up today actually that's
awesome it's not bad is it yeah it's not
it's are you still working
um full-time or have you quit your job
so I was working full-time and then I
left to go self-employed last year
um and I'm stopping that now that's
we've made the decision now that's
full-time problems right thank you very
much and this flip that you're doing
talk to me about how you found it
um it was a funny one actually it was a
very dilapidated house in Matlock again
they wanted to focus on holiday let
Market actually we just went for a
viewing just to see how there was like
flood issues and things like that but
then as soon as you walked out because I
was taking calls for work in the car at
the time so I couldn't do the viewing
you were like it's a really good house
so you went and we booked a second
viewing and negotiated the price the
funny thing is actually shout out to is
Liam Taylor isn't it yeah Legend yeah he
he based in books that same day you had
the viewing he wanted to come be one of
our essays in Matlock actually because I
think he operates in that area as well
and we were just speaking to him about
this house and he was like just put an
offering put a cheeky offered it we're
like that's a bit lower but you know I
don't know if they'll accept they won't
like yeah we'll literally put it off in
that same day and we secured it like a
couple of days later so how much you
buying it for so it was on the market
for 270 and we secured it in the end for
235. uh we probably could have
negotiated a bit more but I think we cut
them at them halfway just because
they're trying to move on with their
lives as well so we're like so you're
gonna buy it for two three five and then
what's what's the what's the vision
well initially we want to convert to
Flats but unfortunately the valuation
came back way lower than it should have
been and the build costs went way higher
than it was meant to
um he quoted as one figure and then more
than doubled it I only got to seeing the
drawings and stuff so that was a
learning go first but um we've always
got the option to turn it into a house
so we have the valuation of it turned
into a yeah a refurbing it as a house
now so so you're just going to just
refurb it do it as a nice house how much
would that cost so we've been quoted
about 60k to be fair bit you're going to
be talking about 295-ish yeah exactly
yeah and then the end value so the
valuation came in at 370 and we actually
think that's quite a conservative value
considering other houses So the plan is
to sell it is that the flag make a
little bit of a chunk of cash what are
the pros and cons between doing because
you're doing Rental rent where you're
making quick cash flow what's the pros
and cons would you say between doing
flips and between controlling properties
I mean uh control and properties is your
day-to-day cash flow ensure in all your
your monthly expenses I guess your your
wages and that you know where whereas
the flip to your big cash injections
your your bigger projects and it opens
more doors for source and BRS for people
as well because you've already done one
yourself so it gives you proof of
concept and uh you know to hand you know
to manage team in that area and how you
can find teams and build teams yeah I'd
say like the flips and like you know
refinancing properties in the future
that's like the longer term goal okay we
want to own more properties and we have
them even running as essays but owning
them ourselves whereas yeah rent to sa
is great cash flow strategy like it's
enabled Brendan to just step away from
you know her property what are you
making like what what are your
properties making so the flat that's
we're not making much of a profit I
think there was one month we made 600
pounds um from that I think this month
will be about 400 pounds it fluctuates a
little bit Yeah and then in Matlock I
love the way you just throw five in
Japan
but that's but to me the hair we teach
if it's making less involved in Japan
don't do it because then if you have a
problem if you have some bad months in
the winter you don't want to be
subsidizing out of your own pocket so
500 pounds kind of like the bottom
bottom end yeah for sure and then for
Matlock we're making at least a grand
property I would say but like that's
fluctuated a bit we made 1500 one month
and then two run from one of them yeah
so two grand profit from one of the
properties yeah yeah we were quite lucky
with that one actually it was awfully
refurbished they're ready to go and out
of the Fall then on average what's the
sort of profit at the moment because
we've just taken on the fourth one we
haven't included that because it always
takes a little bit of time to get going
um although we've just pretty much
covered bills this month with that two
bookings we got on the way down here but
um between two and a half and three
grand how would you say over the last
sort of four months or so from really
going out full time into property making
loads of new friends how would you say
you've changed or grown as as
individuals yeah for me it's definitely
like a big confidence boost and and my
mindset has totally shifted to where
maybe I was skeptical and didn't really
believe in myself to be able to do it
now I'm like I know it's possible I can
see the money coming in and were a
really good team if this is what we're
done what we've done in four months what
we're going to be a competition you know
three four years like so for for us yeah
it's a massive well for me anyway it's
massive yeah and I think for me it's um
you know when you're like I think when
you're in a job as well sometimes you
just feel like this is it for you like
there's no other Avenue to kind of like
make money or like have that Financial
Freedom like you know just to be able to
travel and do things like that
um I think this is just showing me that
actually there is still a way out you
know so yeah it's well you do really
well I mean making that sort of money in
in a short amount of time it's it's
impressive and you've not even really
invested that much on anybody flip now
but the regiment's been very low yeah
the relative how much money were you
putting into the rent to rent like per
rent to rent on average I think the
latest one is probably one of our most
most expensive ones like we put seven
Grand into the one that we've just
converted on a room by room basis yeah
but there was extra expenses with that
because we're doing a Roomba room basis
so we've got the locks that you did it
was less than a couple of grand names
yeah yeah it's a very small yeah and and
actually the third one that we got
because the guy was going traveling it
was only initially meant to be a six
month thing because he was gone
traveling for six months and he just
wanted someone to look after his house
and give him guaranteed rent and he like
doesn't matter well we didn't put
anything into that because it was all
fully furnished already running his
Airbnb before that so all we had to do
was pay the rent and a bit of a deposit
and that's the highest cash flow
um that was actually so there's no money
down no any cash flows what what did you
make last month on that one that's the
one we're making about two
granddaughters
yeah wow yeah that's incredible where
are you finding these rent to rents all
of our so far come off open rent but we
are looking to start speaking to agents
now as well yeah they've all been
landlords direct and that's why they
weren't asking you for any references
because they disliked you and trusted
you what will be your top piece of
advice for people wanting to enter into
the property Market but are a bit Unsure
how to get started I would say just
find someone who's done it yeah join a
mentor program if you have to but if not
Shadow someone that's done it learn from
them and or JV with someone who's doing
it yeah and you bring something to the
table as well maybe you bring the money
to the table but you want to learn the
process from them partner with people
that have done it and they can help you
yeah I'd say jving's probably one of the
best ways to do it we're quite Keen to
do that ourselves now actually um just
keep growing but at the same time we
would love to share our knowledge
actually we're actually just doing an
open house for our recent essay for our
Leicester groups our Midlands group yeah
we're just gonna do a little buffet and
just like everyone come over and have a
look to see how we do it and stuff yeah
yeah that's really cool and you're off
to Bali for a month so
um that sounds exciting are you planning
on doing any property deals while you're
out there or we want to look at some
land actually then yeah you guys are
dark horses so there was some some
massive announcement probably
well definitely if anyone wants to
to get involved in Bali we're definitely
open to it okay we want to maybe employ
the rent around model there but also in
development yeah Brandon how did you
justify the decision to join the academy
after Sarah had like what happened there
I just knew it was the right room to be
in the right Network to be in that I I
recognized the support
um because I was obviously sitting in
the academy calls with Sarah when when
uh when I wasn't in it initially but I
just recognized the support and I knew
the value of being in that Network yeah
where else can you get into a room where
400 other people are wanting to strive
for the same sort of thing you know yeah
what is the best way if people want to
connect to you guys what's the best ways
to get in touch I've got an Instagram
page set up for the social company but
equally if they're on the academy reach
out for our mobile numbers always
respond to whatsapps and stuff so cool
when we'll put your Instagram in the in
the description
um and it's been amazing to see your
journey process and I know this is just
the beginning yeah I know we appreciate
everything you've done for us as well
Samuel honestly instead and it's being I
like I wouldn't have had the confidence
to carry on as far as we have done even
just doing the flip to be fair like um
we invested in some crypto last year and
like lost literary again tens of
thousands
um which was a bit of a crushing defeat
wasn't it um so it was it was like
script has been a bit tough hasn't it
yeah I actually got my wallet hacked as
well oh oh I had the same thing happened
to me did you actually yeah I lost I
didn't lose load I lost about five grand
how much did you lose 60k oh
okay yeah that hurts so you put 60k into
crypto and he got hacked and you lost
everything how did you feel it was weird
because they actually they hacked them
to my email and then they snapchatted
you after resetting my password saying
oh just stolen all of your girlfriend's
assets and I was he was like are you
having a laugh with me like is this a
joke and I went into my wallet and why
did they write to you afterwards just to
rub it in our face that they install and
everything from Sarah yeah that's that's
sick yeah they did overnight as well so
I didn't realize my passwords were being
reset in my email and the police just
aren't interested are they can do
anything it's crypto which is one of the
reasons we've gone back to property as
well actually because like we just
wanted people to see our assets you know
like if they're invested in places like
that you just don't know they're never
secure yeah that's rough man I'm sorry I
didn't even know that so I can see now
why you're a bit timid about the
property stuff how did you feel when you
saw the money coming in from property
initially we were just like I we were
apprehensive we were the first one in
life but like honestly just seeing those
bookings coming in like when we were in
Poland last week our places which was
being booked out we had cleaners set up
and like the whole power teams there so
we just didn't enough to get involved it
was just crazy it's weird to think
there's a way to make money like that
you know like how do you feel now
looking at what you've achieved in the
property side of things how does it feel
I think it's slightly surreal that in
four months we're for placed
my wage and
the businesses is continuing to grow we
now have the network and the skill set
to be able to grow even further in four
months it's not a long time at all so we
just want to see where we end up at the
end of this year I think we could well
I'm excited and if there's anything you
need from me personally anytime drop me
a message we're here for you guys thank
you well done your success
foreign
[Music]